hi
friends welcome back to another episode
of get close i'm your host geo and i'm
bart and today we have a very special
guest and i know i say this about all
our guests but seriously every guest we
have on is a very special guest but this
one
this right here this guy right here is a
very special guest my family my brother
uh silent mike in the hell
i was told this is not a silent mic
interview but you guys get the first
mike far interview
what what is that what do you mean
what's the difference that i'm not gonna
lie to these people but what's the
difference between simon mike and mike
farr yeah what i think is turned into if
you want the serious answer yeah
obviously i think growing up i always
had like a split personality non like
not like not a psychological issue but
i've always felt like two humans yeah
and one is like uh
like the class jokester the class clown
and then one is this introvert shy
introspective emo cat is it a switch
that you turn on and off
uh no the energy in the room kind of
controls it
i control it okay i can but a lot of
it's energy in the room i'm like that
too yeah
like you and i are quite similar like i
feel like i have two parts of me like
one is very introverted i just close up
i don't want to meet anyone i just want
to be in my little corner and there's
another one that's just a complete
goofball i don't give a [ __ ] have zero
shame yeah and um i don't know why i
love that guy yeah i don't know what
brings it in and out you can choose
though but most of the time i've noticed
is hardcore training or hardcore
environments brings out the goofy part
of me really yeah maybe because it gets
too serious maybe it's too serious in
your head and you're like whoa i'm
drowning in the [ __ ] let me goof off so
i don't die oh yeah a couple of my
homies have said like uh yeah i don't
know if bart likes me
and and i was like no no he's just
that's just his face well no it's just
like he's quiet sometimes like he's i'm
quite a lot yeah and that's like me
yeah interesting what did they say about
me are they like jill's a big [ __ ] they
actually didn't even recognize you're in
the building
they said geo who was she even there no
dude i'm like you uh depending on the
i'm like very introverted but depending
on the room if it if i feel that the
energy is high and good i'm like cool my
work's done let me just blend into the
background but if the energy seems kind
of somber and i feel like people want to
feel good but they just can't for
whatever reason then i'll come in and
i'll try to like bring up the vibe i
think i played that role in my family
yes i think that's where is that where
it comes from i don't think so my dad
was kind of that guy in the family oh
the like the jokester or like the energy
or like the i don't know where mine
comes from but like if you want to get
deep early here in the podcast
some of it for sure is like a lesser
than feeling and like needing attention
attention seeking behavior how i don't
know where did that because i don't know
i've done a lot of therapy and we have
no idea are you middle child no there's
only two youngest kids youngest child
and my parents were dope no like crazy
i've had like trauma but not like that
should affect that so you can't even
blame it on the environment it's just
you i think it's honestly just me and
that's why like i don't want to change
it either some of it's adhd stuff some
you know i don't want to change it
because i do think it's just me oh [ __ ]
but is there like a
super powers to it i think so kind of
like we've talked about adhd or like
being extra sensitive you and i've
talked about like i think
some of those things although it makes
my life a little bit more difficult
sometimes because i do feel real deep
yeah yeah because sometimes you know
when the switch is to one side there's
definitely stuff that you're like oh man
i don't feel normal
normal yeah or i feel like these bad
sides to it but then when the switch is
on the other side there's also this like
other like potential that can be like
harnessed too i don't know if it's just
because i'm a hater but i don't want to
be like everybody else either i see what
do you mean what do you mean like the
typical dude and i know some guys are
out there like i have feelings like the
typical douchebag dude has no feelings
like doesn't care like just [ __ ]
[ __ ] i really love the curse on here
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] are you kidding me
bro i don't know you can't tell lies i
don't [ __ ] no [ __ ] no i don't i don't
that's what i'm saying i don't [ __ ]
have issues
tell them baby i only [ __ ] beautiful
kind women all right
we're saying play play because uh
yesterday was halloween and we went
trick-or-treating with tyka and bart
called him play a play and taiko was so
pissed taekwon's like don't call me i'll
play a player not today not tomorrow and
he was yelling it we were outdoors and
bart was like 10 feet away from taika
and he's like don't call me i'll play a
player he was so pissed he has no clue
what it means it's still so funny i love
it no i love it it's like when uh they
would make fun of bart's name calling a
bartender bartender and he's like don't
call me that i don't even know what i
mean you got mad i was in second grade
yeah i don't know what bartender means i
don't know but what'd you get mad it
just sounded like he was trying to hurt
me somehow people called me michael fart
a lot oh
that didn't feel good yeah
they called me joe mama that's good
though not really it doesn't even fit
your name really it doesn't well yeah it
doesn't um but before we start going in
on me yes your mama um hey man i still
have some no i don't i really i'll call
you like geography or something nah it's
not even cool but at least it's spelled
the same kind of no it's not i mean you
are correct they're not it's not a cool
dish oh no uh but the reason why i'm so
stoked that you're here is because yeah
you kind of you kind of already touched
on a little bit we have a little bit
more of a mic far on here and i love
that i think
uh you're someone honest you're looking
at me like i'm talking some [ __ ] no
she's gonna be kind no i'm looking at
you i mean this from the heart man
you're someone that we really look up to
and we're inspired by and we're
motivated by um and yeah we [ __ ] around
a lot but i think it's just because
that's the type of relationship we've
built right like we both love the tough
love we're both like [ __ ] you bro hate
you but we know that it's all love um
and yeah we wanted to bring you here
because like i said you're someone that
we look up to we're inspired by and
you're like our people you know like
um last year not even last year i think
the year before that
um i think as covid was hitting you were
like
let's open up a gym and uh this
obviously you didn't know this was gonna
happen yeah but you were like [ __ ] it
i'm gonna still keep going forward with
it like
who knows what the future holds because
nobody knew what the [ __ ] was happening
with kovid and and you like triumphed
and you open up [ __ ] third street
barbell
um your co-founder of that right yeah
yeah okay the legendary jim mcd yeah um
and that was [ __ ] tight as [ __ ] you
know cause people would be like we were
all getting crushed man i mean me too
yeah all gyms in california all gyms
across the nation getting crushed all
fitness but how easy would it have been
for you to be like yo we just picked the
wrong time like no one could have
predicted this [ __ ] but it's the wrong
time and how many people would have
thrown the towel you know what i mean it
was probably worse than i even
anticipated absolutely dude yeah they
said two weeks we signed the lease
we signed the lease technically i think
in may 2020.
so we we knew what was happening you
know and then as best was my dumb ass
could as i predicted all right it can't
go on for two years right yeah like
nobody thought i honest and i was being
like i thought i was being cautious like
all right six months i was like six
months of chaos and then we'll [ __ ]
yeah yeah and it kind of was right it's
absolutely a little bit less messy um
yeah i don't know yeah my mentor texted
me my first mentor my high school
basketball coach and uh dean stark shout
out to dean and uh what's up dean the
best he really is and he texted me like
heard that i was opening it and he's
like what are you doing i'll say i don't
know man i'll talk to you in like five
years i'm either a genius or i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] we'll find out bro and
that [ __ ] i think i think that
personality or just that tenacity and i
think that mindset is what we look up to
what i look up to because it's like well
yeah i look up to you guys
i'm just following your little footsteps
we're not here to talk about us you know
what i mean like i want to shout you out
like i want to i want to shed some light
on you i want you to know that like we
see your hard work you know and i i want
to share that because like it would have
just been easy to be like nah
i'm gonna wait or i'm gonna do whatever
or just talk down to yourself to the
point where you back out right so
it was a huge triumph you're still open
till this day you're in yeah you're in
sacramento um
and and it's not just a gym it's a
really dope community um and in addition
to that like anyone could purchase like
your apparel line that goes with uh with
this gym aka this [ __ ] dope ass
community uh what's it called the
apparel oh yeah good company there it is
that's like more like our just do it you
know it's like good company buy third
street yeah i love it i love it and i
even love the messaging behind it
because it's like
you just want to be around literally
good company you know you want to be
around good people that are going to
inspire you motivate you like you're my
good company and hopefully we're your
good company 100 no you guys are all
part of the inspiration behind all that
too like jim mcd technically came up
with the name so i don't want to take
credit for any of that but like good
company right there yeah good company um
third street's just like a no-brainer i
think marketing-wise because we're on
third street you know and it's such a
cool name sounds cool yeah
already old-school barbell stuff's like
that you know like west side barbell was
a west side and i think culver city yeah
of san francisco or whatever you know so
like it just kind of hit me that but
good company because of all the travel i
got to do and hang out with people like
you like it just makes so much sense to
me that
i would way rather do the shittiest
thing in the world with you two
than the coolest thing in the world with
two people i hate yeah you know what i
mean yeah that's like there's just no
doubt about it yeah i love that okay so
if that wasn't enough right so you're
going through that [ __ ] you're like [ __ ]
it i'm gonna stick it out i'm gonna open
up this tight ass gym uh nothing around
it in the area so if you're everyone
that i go check it out because it's
[ __ ] rather [ __ ] and you're like okay
downtown sec yes um prime location yeah
dope parking lot dude unheard of nice
um
you have dope ass apparel it has a
street vibe to it i absolutely love it i
love the baggy fit i rock it all the
time uh okay so if that wasn't already
enough you're like you know what
i have a pretty cool personality this
let's [ __ ] continue with the [ __ ]
podcast and now you have a podcast 50
facts
um
dude that [ __ ] is just all good vibes
too it's it's all about like
um
i don't know you you guys just have
really good commentary about everything
it's not just fitness it's you were
saying you're doing movie reviews right
now
um it's a little transformation kind of
like you guys starting this new podcast
because we've all done all this so long
i think you know like it's got to evolve
in whether your audience evolves with
you you find a new audience i think you
you kind of have to do what you want to
do at the end of the day um because then
you can't continue yeah we're just
talking sets and reps i've done it for
12 years i don't want to do that no more
you know you can watch
the billion deadlift how to's i've done
on everybody's youtube channel if you
want to learn how to deadlift did i have
one of those
i'm guaranteeing no i guarantee you
probably not no guaranteed yeah i'm sure
mike is probably on the barbell channel
teaching us something guaranteed and so
like the deadlift hasn't changed yeah so
why am i going to try to complicate it
you know yeah not that my deadlift
how-to is the best because you find new
words to make it more fun and more
digestible yes
yeah and then i do in-person coaching
like that you know and i've evolved my
brain a little bit but i just don't want
to make that content a little bit is a
good i'm glad you put that in there
because it has evolved just a little bit
yeah because it doesn't evolve a lot
your brain yeah no my brain is um you
ever seen limitless
yeah they took a microscopic
video of what's happening in my head to
put up on the animation of when he's on
that pill no dude it's a hamster in a
[ __ ] hamstring when you're like
[ __ ] going through the galaxy and
[ __ ] and there's stars and yeah that's
actually an x-ray you're stupid
uh okay so if that was enough so we have
the gym we have the apparel line we have
the podcast
this guy is like hey you know what
let's get on twitch let's just show
everybody my dope ass [ __ ] gaming
skills
i got good
you've been gaming for a long time yeah
forever damn i mean i started when i was
like in first grade with duck hunt and i
just sucked and i just never got good at
any game you just never got into it duck
come was cool i was just never good i
would be black i hate that [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] that though he was kind of annoying
what do you laugh like he's like
yeah he was kind of stupid yeah i would
be playing like across the living room
right and i'm like [ __ ] this game i'm
shooting point blank and i'm still
missing yeah why are you trying to snipe
you got to be up in the thing and then i
play like super mario sucks street
fighter suck wait what the hell is this
thing what joystick arcade arcade what
is that you talk about alone time
arcade you know like what like uh yeah
yeah
i didn't really like i don't like
fighting games yeah that's like shooters
sucked out all of them but you gotta
like you it's kind of like anything else
and this sounds so corny but gaming is
kind of like lifting like you just have
to grind it out
what do you mean like you should have to
keep dying yeah i can't i can't bro i'd
rather just go outside and run we play
competitive sometimes so like me and my
boy kyle shout out kyle he uh he's good
he's good good i'm good he's good good
and so we've like gambled i don't i
think it's legal they're called wagers
uh how like just friendly bets no you go
to a website oh wow and you sign up you
throw down like 10 bucks or a certain
amount of tokens for this website and
then you go head to head with a team um
depending on the game you play there's
different rules but we play like battle
royales and so um it's called the kill
race so you know what a battle royale is
yeah
so imagine island imagine hunger games
okay it's a video game hunger
depending on the game a bunch of people
drop down and depending on the game
sometimes you drop down with nothing and
you have to run around and find guns and
then the last one standing wins yeah
like fortnight fortnite was one of the
biggest battle royale probably probably
the first one that like evolved it to
pop culture but there's other ones dude
h1z1 is one of the first ones ever
and one we were really good at was
called blackout um
and we would just throw wagers on it so
then you run down and when you're
betting um you're technically on the
same team there's
four people on a team but you two are
homies and then me and kyle are homies
and so i don't hear you or talk to you
and me and kyle run off and we're
fighting other teams of four you're
fighting other teams of four and whoever
kills the most people and then we'll
eventually have to fight each other no
because we're technically in game we're
on the same in the game we're on the
same team but because the wager we're
not got it yeah and so we just lay that
a little bit you see [ __ ] like that but
it's competitive so point being though
like a couple wagers we got our ass
kicked we lost 20 bucks or you come
across the wrong team or you play a
ranked game which basically means like
online there's like a point system to
rank up and the more better you get you
play only better people it's skill based
um and yeah you get your ass kicked for
a while but you just got to keep playing
keep playing learn adjust and learn oh i
was really bad with my rotations there
it's just like oh i was really weak in
my hammies i gotta go do more rdos and
just grind it out it's cool oh my god
now i i don't know man maybe i should
give it another try but like i remember
playing stupid games like street fighter
or gran turismo yeah and then like with
my little sister who's like six years
younger than me so i'm talking about
maybe like i'm 15 or something and she's
like eight or nine is that good math no
are you lost is that wrong that's about
right i can't really do it all right
there we go um and dude she would be
wrecking me she was [ __ ] but did you
have fun no i [ __ ] threw the remote
control and i was like [ __ ] this game
and like i had like anger issues because
i do well i mean raging is a big thing i
do feel gamey is another thing one of
the few
that people enjoy and suck
yeah like if you really suck at
basketball you're not going to play it
all the time you'll watch nba or
something that's me i really suck but i
love playing
you're a unique human i [ __ ] suck at
basketball i [ __ ] love it but most
people don't right you don't suck though
yeah you're a good athlete
good
[Laughter]
there's now though there's a game for
everybody well i could find a video game
you guys would like yeah
for me i think like it doesn't matter if
i suck or if i'm good at something it
has to scratch an itch that feels good
so with basketball i love like team
energy i like being physical i like uh
like physical without
hurting each other too much grab the
ball away from each other and then you
know like when you guys are on like when
two or three players on a certain
wavelength that's above everyone else
it's like somehow i have this
communication you know i'ma do something
they know i'm gonna do and you make this
play and like man that was [ __ ] magic
i like that i feel like that happens in
games too then no that huff isn't games
for sure
i just don't feel that in the game maybe
people are throwing me alley-oops in the
game i'm just sucking so hard i don't
know what that was happening we had a
tournament in my basketball team growing
up so i had the same coach for four
years guys shouted out earlier and then
i coached with him for four years i was
his assistant um he's been the varsity
coach in my school i think he's the most
winningest basketball coach in
california's history um wow yeah stud
and just like more than john wooden john
wooden was college okay or high school
but probably more honestly more games uh
i think he's had a longer career too um
which helps but what he's really good at
is like a holistic approach which is
like the school i went to also but like
he can make anybody get on the same page
and like find a common enemy and like
the worst kid on the team at like a big
competitive school is often bitching
about not getting playing time or oh i'm
better geo why she he gets everybody on
the same page every year for like 30
years he's just got like these that was
beautiful he's so good he's got like
these hitler s characteristics very
culty yeah
no you just you know it's like little
things let's cut everyone together and i
hate him
he's
his uh like favorite coaches john wood
though
and there's little things i don't know
if you much read much about john when i
was just talking to a friend about john
wooden um because she started getting uh
he's a legendary basketball coach for
ucla and and arguably just the best
general coach in history in my opinion
wow um if you've listened to this
podcast you are well aware and know that
i'm obsessed with playing best fiends
year round but i especially love playing
best fiends during the holiday season
it's the perfect little pick-me-up and a
mental break when i need to just chill
out from all this holiday action
best fiend has it all an amazing story
line collectible fiends the cutest
they're just so cute these little bugs
that just attack these nasty slugs all
day i can play it honestly forever um
and tons of fun puzzles i can't put it
down honestly i cannot that's my little
escape at night when i have some me time
and it's quite possibly the best puzzle
game out there honestly yep i said it
for everyone listening right now please
do yourself a favor and download best
fiends free today on the app store or
google play that's friends without the r
best fiends trust me you're not gonna
hate it you're gonna be so in love with
it you're gonna be like thank you
geo
you're welcome in advance
thank you so much skillshare for
sponsoring this podcast i absolutely
love this service and i love that you
guys exist skillshare is an online
learning community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore real projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
okay you guys might not believe this but
you're a creative person
and if you're like no i'm not i'm you
know i'm not really creative i don't
know how to draw i don't know whatever
no that's not true if you got up today
and you dressed yourself
and you look pretty cool and you match
that's pretty damn creative you know if
you did your hair that's creative you
are a creative person okay and if that
means you last picked up a paint brush
yesterday or in grade school
that doesn't matter you can explore your
creativity and be inspired all through
skillshare also skillshare's entire
catalog of classes which they have a ton
i'm talking about uh creative writing to
photography and all sorts of photography
when i say that okay it could be like
professional camera digital to film
to even iphone photography i'm talking
about interior design i mean the
creative list goes on and on and on
please check it out but they offer
subtitles in spanish french portuguese
and dutch okay so please explore your
creativity at skillshare.com
slash a bill
and get one month free trial of premium
membership that's one month of a premium
membership at skillshare.com
bail so my friend just got a a a
coaching job shout out uh doing strength
and conditioning and and she's a female
late 20s and she's coaching high school
dudes how to lift and she's real smart
but like there's a whole dynamic going
on right yeah so she picked up a bunch
of books and showed them to me she's
like yeah i heard this is good i was
like no like yeah that's john wood read
every john wooden book you can and one
little example is like he talks about
preparation and and doing things as a
team and being ready for um kind of like
routine or superstition if you want to
call you can call whatever you want
right but every beginning of the season
you'd have everybody on the team sit
down on the bleachers and he would teach
them and have them tie their shoes
together
what is that about preparation yeah you
don't tie your shoes right if you don't
do the small things right how are we
going to do the big things right and if
we don't do them together how are we not
going to do the thing unison yep yeah
that's awesome yeah and so then
eventually he doesn't do that every
practice or whatever but it's just to
get the point across like hey we got to
do these little things right so now we
can get prepared so we get our mind
right to get the other things right um
that's why they do like push-ups by the
numbers of the military yeah 100 people
right we're doing one two three one two
two three two so
of course you could bust out maybe 20
push-ups in five seconds this might take
10 seconds and instead of everyone doing
working out alone together let's work
out together together so you build this
common bond you are a team you're
suffering together you're at the same
pace and then when everyone stands back
up there's this extra electricity in the
air that kind of ties all this together
yeah and besides your nazi joke like
common enemy is how you build a team
like you have to have a common enemy um
but we had a phrase back in the day uh
that my coach would say make a play so
momentum's down you guys probably watch
tons of sports and all those out there
like whatever it is basketball like the
opposite team gets a big old dunk and
like if you're live in that game or if
you're playing in that game you do feel
like your blood go like out of your body
you're like damn that guy is better than
me yeah you have like that life bar but
it's like a morality bar
yeah right momentum is a real thing in
sports and so we are our terms always
make a play like all right then they're
coming out i'm going to get a steal then
i'm going to steal i'm going to show my
team i get that adrenaline in gaming so
like you're in a fight in these battle
royales and these guys are in the trees
over there and my team's kind of like
i'm about to play the play but i'm about
to knock two of these kids out you know
like then my team's gonna get up and
we're gonna i just love that i get
[ __ ] chills
yo some battle royales bro you're hard
to be fine so it feels like you're
playing basketball kinda bro a good
battle royale so then the other thing
with the battle royale is with time uh
they call it the storm or the zone it'll
close the map
so it funnels everybody to one part of
the map
hella fun so people start to die also
and once you die in that game you're
gone you got to go reset to a different
map
so the zone keeps coming in and so then
you might have like 30 people in like
this little square and i'm hiding behind
the water bottle
just the head diving you know just
waiting for the kyle i need cover bro
and you're just [ __ ] hyped it's sick
bro that's cool no i got like a
basketball field sometimes wow damn
that's fun and what game is this uh any
battle royale oh i see right now we're
playing apex um and there's like a
ranked mode so it's competitive how fun
oh [ __ ] i might even disappear i don't
know we'll try it out that's the issues
you can disappear in this stuff oh no
yeah cause you get locked in time starts
to change beginning at covid before we
open the gym i was streaming 16 hours a
day oh my god how did you eat oh i
didn't oh on stream you just eat yeah
what about i got a pee or poop
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah what do you think was
happening yeah you just leave it running
well i don't know i thought you like oh
call tune back guys you gotta shut the
stream off no yeah you just leave it on
a screen wow back in the day you could
play music now it's like dmc8 out so you
can't really play music but yeah just
turn on like a dope playlist let the
people jam damn that's [ __ ] tight
okay so uh you street okay so like i i'm
like [ __ ] listing on your [ __ ] okay
so if that wasn't enough yeah you're
twitching um
twitching that was stupid yeah i'm a mom
you're a mom joke yeah i know twitch is
the name of that dope dancer right
thank you for trying to save it i don't
know no it wasn't dumb it was a [ __ ]
dumb he's on ellen now i don't know
dancer oh okay like like her
yeah her bat her dj guy but he dances oh
yeah i know he talked about he kills it
yeah he's good uh okay so if that wasn't
enough you're also on youtube still
pumping out content yeah um and then i
just want to brag about your lips a bit
because you're kind of strong man i used
to be yeah
okay this is i was asking him before a
podcast i was like what are your best
lips so it's squat 590.
uh bench 405 and then a 705 deadlift
that's uh yeah that's not a weird [ __ ]
man that's right i've been doing a lot
was that is that almost 1700
yeah if i could throw them together it'd
be about 17 i think
the best total total though is 1600
that's really good yeah damn you're just
like
whatever when i started like
powerlifting powerlifting i was thrown
into the
lion's den or whatever you know yeah i
was lifting with the best in the world
yeah so
i would compare myself so you compare
your numbers to that and it just seems
so far away yeah yeah for sure for sure
yeah i get it yeah and so like my
numbers are okay but also from where you
started it's a huge jump though for sure
i made progress but the the biggest
thing is i've just done it for 12 years
most people can't say they've done
anything for 12 years yeah yeah you know
i haven't lived it for 12 years like
consistently what have you done for 12
years um youtube yeah you're right and
and look how successful you guys are
like you just chip away at it like you
may not be the biggest youtubers in the
absolute world but you guys chipped your
way to the [ __ ] pretty damn good spot
if you do anything for 12 years i've
been lifting for 20 years and my of 1100
total
yeah big bicep so you look good naked
hey you're above average
for sure
you're above average it's just all
genetics and i hate to like wean it down
to that because it demoralizes some
people but it doesn't really demoralize
me that's why i talk about it but like
there's kids that have
powerlifted for a year that are way
stronger than me [ __ ] yeah man and it is
genetics it is leverages it is like i
don't know if there's a bunch of factors
that [ __ ] go into it man but that's
everything you could argue everything
right like because someone could have
done youtube for 12 years and not got 10
000 subscribers yeah about all the
things that you've done like personally
athletically even from basketball yeah
in your like
personal life with your emotionally
anything like what's the theme or the
most proud of
i don't know that's probably the hardest
question i've ever been asked
that's part of like what keeps me going
is that i i can't like uh enjoy small
victories i got like a chip on my
shoulder kind of like the
need for attention yeah um there's no
reason i can think of like professional
therapists all this stuff can't like dig
it out either but i have like this
lesser than feeling but there's
definitely something that's like
a small fire that has to keep you going
and where does that come from i don't
know i don't know where it comes from
but i do want attention and i want to be
patted on the back um and where did you
get that the most do you think um i
don't know i guess the one thing like
one thing that i am proud of is that
regardless of like money or like trends
or whatever and like social media and
especially fitness i've always been me i
think that's like something i'm actually
proud of um i've never changed in my
personal life i've never trained on
online and although we joked about like
the mike farson mic like that sounded
like dudes still me i was like that way
in high school too i'd show out and act
a fool
but i've never i've never changed my
morals i've missed out on
multiple six figures denying
sponsorships i don't believe in as i'm
sure you guys have too we were talking
about in the kitchen
yeah you know and so like that kind of
stuff i'm proud of um
but like lifting i'm not really proud of
i guess doing it for a long time is
school
but i think that's the [ __ ] though that
lasts
longer than anything yeah i think the
fact that you're able to one like never
be satisfied like
i mean we can look at that different
ways right and like net that feeling of
never being satisfied can be looked at
like damn like you should like that's
bad yeah it's kind of a superpower it's
kind of what like we were talking about
like it sucks because i never like feel
great i try to for my team like when we
opened the gym i went and bought a
really expensive whiskey for jim and we
cheered it with some of the boys that
helped us with construction but like i
didn't feel like [ __ ] yeah open the gym
i've never felt that not once not once
in your whole life what about basketball
winning a game winning any type of
championship or i think like in a game i
don't know man i think i think i'm just
so self-critical we joke about me being
a hater like about other people and how
many i hate so many people and judge
them so hard but it's because i judge
myself so hard yeah and so like if i win
a basketball game it's like yeah i
should have won that basketball game
it's not like yeah good job mikey yeah
like no way white guy isn't supposed to
win any basketball games yeah but in my
head i'm not bro what are you a [ __ ]
freak like what like six five i'm just a
[ __ ] stud
i really am in my head dude and what you
need is someone on the court azure plane
just holding a mirror and running with
you the whole time yeah i did yeah yeah
i need a house of mirrors yeah i need
your house wait wait why the mirror i
could see how cool so he knows that he's
not six five like literally like on the
mirror it's marked five eight and six
five yeah so there's like a huge dip
like there's like a silhouette of jordan
in the background yeah so i could tell i
don't know i uh i do think i'm special
and that sounds really stupid in what
way i don't know do i just think i'm
different
do you think everyone's different or
yeah not snowflake different not like oh
i'm i'm unique like i think i got
something in me you know and so i think
it's always tight i think i'm just
always trying to prove that
whatever it is basketball for sure
basketball is the only thing i was like
what's that
what's the uh so before power so
powerlifting found some success yeah
basketball found some success what did
you find success in before basketball
just played basketball my whole life
that's all i knew so starting in like
first grade or kindergarten love
basketball probably i played a little
bit of soccer and stuff like every kid
but loved basketball probably third
fourth grade so that was as that early
on that was like your first taste of
success yeah probably probably i guess
uh and little things like uh i did get
special treatment but i think it was
partially because of special and
partially situations we had a a really
dope ladies basketball coach at my
school um
he had his son coached a duke and he had
a highly successful career at my school
back in the day
and he ran a huge summer camp and he had
connections to all the big public
schools in the city and so because my
school was tiny you guys know my school
is tiny 24 kids graduating class uh
that's real small the smallest thing
ever uh and so like the competitiveness
there i was a big fish was this school
uh was the basketball even part of the
school or you have to play in the
outside part of the school no part of
the school but no not for little kids
but high school was serious and we were
good despite having no tryouts and like
not being that into sports
but if you had 24 kids isn't that half
the classes in basketball yeah
holy well yeah i mean we only had
varsity in junior varsity we didn't have
freshman teams yeah and then yeah like
you'd have because the basketball team's
already like 10 11 12 kids talk about
shout out my coach again i'm just
pumping him up but he had a year where
he had six guys on the team and he i
think he won league no
god how does that how do you even play
he he gets he got like alumni to come
back for practices or he was just so
creative in practices yeah you couldn't
even scrimmage
that was the year i was in eighth grade
yeah
crazy damn that's insane imagine he's
like coaching in china and he has access
to the full genetic pool or even even a
public school even a public school here
right yeah like where he gets to like
choose a trial yeah like hey you you
over there six nine guy come here yeah
damn yeah random we were just good but
long story short i was uh the basketball
camp of the summer was stupid
competitive because all the public
school kids would come but i think it
was like sixth or seventh grade and up
to high school um but my dad was part of
the basketball program there and my mom
taught at the school and so the and and
the the coach knew me he let me go as
like a fourth grader and that's when i i
guess i kind of was proud of that i was
in like fourth grade i was always that
kid like
banging out on some like seventh graders
you know
do you think um that
feeling not that you're not special i
think you think i'm special
you know it too as soon as i said that
you guys did you want you questioned it
for the audience but you're like yeah he
is a little different oh stop it um and
i know you're [ __ ] around a lot yeah
um but do you think that might also come
from like your parents pumping you up a
lot i don't think so because i thought
of that too because i have because i
also have like this dynamic of like
feeling lesser than two and like wanting
to prove myself i don't know i i have a
complicated brain and i've tried to gone
to therapy for 20 years try to figure it
out and i still haven't figured it out i
don't know because i don't think that
was the case either i honestly and i'm
33 now it's not like i see my parents i
think they're amazing but i don't have
them on that pedestal hero thing anymore
you know and i still think they did a
really good job like they told me when i
suck they told me to work hard they told
me effort like they didn't just blow me
i didn't like do [ __ ] and they say like
yeah like my dad was real man if i did a
[ __ ] painting he's like yeah that's not
very good you know like you know what i
mean like especially i was like a
teenager like no i didn't i didn't
because i think i probably would have
turned into a narcissist if i got that
it's weird because i i know exactly what
you're talking about um and like the
most in the most honest sense because
it'll sound like egotistical but it's
not
like
uh
growing up i'll feel something
like
i'm the for some reason i'm the
the
lead in this movie or like destined for
something bigger yeah and it will
literally happen yeah like i don't like
for example uh my the earliest memory
might be um like let's say my freshman
year in drumline right i don't know why
but i i knew i was going to be the best
drummer and then all freshmen have to
play this thing called the pit which are
playing xylophone bells cowbells all all
kinds of like just the [ __ ]
instruments and you're supposed to
practice on the side to audition to be
in the drum line right so you're just
playing like all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
like random things
and then right
on that ass yeah and then there was uh
randomly in
to break like the first movement and the
second movement they needed someone to
play this crazy solo on a brake drum and
usually you don't offer solos to the pit
because you're just so many other great
players you just need a different sound
and then i just knew it was going to be
me and then one day they're like bart
you're going to be playing this on the
break yeah yeah and then when uh i've
had stuff like that yeah and when one of
the symbol guys quit
um it was me and like four other
freshmen were auditioning i just knew i
was gonna get it and then i got it and
then uh so fast forward to like junior
year in high school got kicked out a
bunch of schools right i go to the
school that my cousin was going to he's
doing really good academically i was
i've always been good at math but i'm
also
people know me as my cousin's reject
cousin that got kicked out and that's
why he's going here when i was in my
calculus class
um i found out that there's a class
president
and for some reason i looked the teacher
in the eyes she looked me in the eye and
i knew she was going to pick me
and there's some smart kids that have
4.0 [ __ ] 4.5s or whatever but she
maybe felt your juju too and i'm like a
one point something kid
from another high school that's a
failure you know and then even into the
marine corps i was like i look at the my
drill instructor and i knew i was gonna
get picked to be squad lead and it was
just it's just weird what kind of
[ __ ] spider-man [ __ ] spidey sense
is y'all i don't know so i know what
he's talking about and then so like i
feel the same thing so i feel the same
thing where sometimes like
if i assume the destiny and if i don't
live up to the destiny i actually get
really down it's already like a given
yeah do you think that relates to like
where where why you are where you are
like obviously you guys both work really
really hard and you're organized and all
this stuff and you've done it for 12
years et cetera et cetera but do you
think a little bit that's just like nah
this is kind of i don't like destiny we
were joking last night about manifesting
and destiny and i don't really i love
the idea of it because i love like a
little mystery harry potter magic but i
don't actually believe it to my core you
know yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i love it i love it bro i wish i had
some jedi tricks but i don't actually
believe it in my core i think that's
probably why i like this [ __ ] i want to
believe it and i don't yeah uh but you
know you're like yeah i knew i was gonna
like have an audience i knew i did i
don't know that i don't know i kind of i
i never knew i was gonna have an
audience or be known by more than my
friends in a circle maybe not no no one
knew like youtube was going to be a
career but did you know you were
destined for something
that no bro so i'm in uh you did i don't
know this one's just this one's just
stupid and funny uh i'm i'm playing
basketball i'm playing my tits off like
uh so i went to junior college played as
much as a five eight guy could play no
no
i played yeah get him babe
more than a five eight two nice i've
seen mike play is really really good and
you saw me fat and old i was going ham
so i played junior college got like a
bad rap didn't like it whatever quit
working out so hard i opened my own gym
i'm working out i'm working as a
personal trainer gym i'm coaching in
high school your own gym back in the day
too yeah 2009 hope in my first year yeah
yeah yeah private training studio yeah i
didn't know that yeah it failed but
that's probably why you didn't know we
did it didn't go very far i uh i want to
say he was destined he was like i'm not
a special guy that's going to fail at
james talk about being the opposite of
like uh uh
narcissist no yeah
i am cute well the opposite that you
said i was like of like feeling
accomplished or or proud yes or not
ashamed i guess
that was important that was one of the
things i i've like i did keep a secret
because i was ashamed that it that your
gym didn't do well i get it i was
ashamed of like how it looked in a sense
because i was 18 i spent five grand to
open it it was my life's sake wow that's
a lot yeah uh you know i thought now it
was all craigslist yeah you know and i
did it all on my own and all this stuff
and then it failed and like i was
ashamed i didn't even tell people i
opened the gym until like kind of
recently
and then i went to super training and i
went you know i'm hanging out with the
best lifters in the world like i'm not
gonna tell them like yeah i'm a gym
owner like i felt dumb yeah i own a gym
and a fail what about you yeah they have
one whole squad rack yeah it felt stupid
that's crazy but you were 18 man at
eighteen nineteen [ __ ] did i have okay
nineteen i bought a car that's good yeah
not a [ __ ] gym i wasn't even thinking
of my own business i think my business
was lazy because i didn't wanna work for
nobody else that's great i used to think
people that owned a this is how [ __ ]
ignorant i was yeah um in order for you
to own a business you have to own a
building like i was like i'm never going
to be a business owner because i can't
afford a building this won't make you
laugh i thought everyone who owned a
business is [ __ ] balling
that would make me laugh that makes
sense that's probably thinking the same
thing a lot of people because you need a
business yeah that's true that's what i
thought too but a lot of people like
just get by owning a business yeah like
i'd like see someone i'm like oh you
want a donut shop yeah you must be rich
yeah and then later on i find out that
it's really tough it's hard to scrape by
now you've been making 40 grand yeah and
the your donut shop pretty much stopped
sales at like three p.m people only eat
it for breakfast you're like oh wow
there's all these other problems out of
yeah thank you so much to betterhelp for
sponsoring this podcast okay so i'm
going to take a minute right now because
i really want you guys to listen
we need to take care of our mental
health the same way we take care of our
physical health
mental health is right up there so if
there's something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional you'll be
matched with a therapist in under
48 hours this is not a crisis hotline
this is not self-help i'm talking about
professional therapy done securely
online
there is a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas and what i love
about this service is that
you know
when we talk to a therapist and i'm
talking about maybe like one then we go
ugh
yeah we didn't like it therapy is not
for us no that just means that one
particular therapist is not for you
but because it's better help they have
like i said a broad range of
professionals that you can choose from
so if one is just not aligning with you
or you're just not vibing with them
guess what you have a ton of other
professionals that you can talk to until
you find the one that fits you and your
needs the best so please do yourself and
your mental health a favor because
you guys deserve it please visit
slash
betterhelp.com
that's a better help h-e-l-p
dot com slash bill b-e-a-w
and you're gonna get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
bill for 10 off again your first month
thank you so much to skylight frame for
sponsoring this podcast if you guys
haven't already heard me talk about
skylight frame since like forever let me
introduce you to them skylight frame is
a photo frame that you can update
instantly by email from anywhere so it's
a digital
photo frame um and i ended up getting
this for members of my family and
because as you guys know i used to live
in california now i live in vegas
and i miss them but it's super rad that
now they have skylight frame because i'm
able to drop them some really cool
memories whenever it is that i miss them
or i you know or or i think about them
um i just email a photo to them and it
automatically gets uploaded into their
frame and then i'll get a text or a
video or a picture saying hey did you do
this or oh this is so cool or oh my god
this is so cute and it's such a cool
feeling to let them know that you love
them
in such a simple
but very deep way um for everyone
listening right now
we have a special offer you're going to
get 10 off your purchase of a skylight
frame when you go to skylightframe.com
and enter code bill b-e-a-w that's right
ten dollars off your purchase of a
skylight frame just go to
skylightframe.com and enter code bill
that's
i s-k-y-l-i-g h t f r a m e dot com and
don't forget the promo
enter code bail
b-e-a-w
my dumb destiny story so i'm training
myself other people and i'm playing
basketball probably four or five hours a
day lifting two or three hours a day i
was gonna go walk on a d1 school best
shape of my life i'm [ __ ] duncan i'm
feeling
sick after a workout me and my buddies
go to a subway
and this korean lady's making my
sandwich
she looks me dead in the eye
she said you
you remember me what
you're gonna be famous
i don't know where she said that short
of god what did your friends say they're
just kind of looking at me and i'll
laugh it off i probably crack a joke
back like i'm gonna remember you you're
like just put the olive oil and the mayo
i said no mayo
wait have you seen her before no
i'm at a random subway never seen her
again either maybe she was a witch
that's [ __ ] don cheadle i know so i'm
waiting what do you mean you know that
movie with nicholas cage where he does
the whole family thing where he's like
he's like at the cash register and then
nicholas cage he's like a stalker guy
yeah wait no what is it called i think
the family or maybe family guy yeah and
then he uh he ends up like going like
that and then he wakes up angel and then
it was the alternative life he could
have had and it was his family he had
kids and he had a family man family man
yeah and then and he fought at first he
he doesn't like it he loves like the hot
[ __ ] the ferrari and then he falls in
love with it
yeah and then don cheadle shows up and
goes no no not you not you i love this
and he goes well
you know and then bam he was back into
the
new york stockbroker life and that's
that's her don cheadle yeah so what
happened so you've heard her say that i
mean did that really stick with you and
you realize obviously it gets me that
was just 15 years ago so i just can't
wait to like win my oscar whatever i'm
supposed to do and like shout her out
but it's tight right because like that's
crazy you're only 33 man i say only bro
i feel old right but like if you look at
like look at all these motivational
memes and [ __ ] they're like
uh this like [ __ ] big baller shot
caller like turned 60 something when he
had his big break my number one is bill
withers who's probably my favorite
artist of all time maybe at least my
favorite voice of all time um i don't
think he made a record or even was known
to his 45 40 48 you know what i mean
yeah like we're still babies in the game
yeah for sure like there's definitely
times where i get down about [ __ ] and
i'm like [ __ ] man i mean it like
everyone says like don't compare
yourself to people but you do you have
to right you kind of have to see what
the playing field is like and you kind
of have to see where people are at not
that i like
hang on to that [ __ ] i think it's
[ __ ] you have to if you don't then
we're all just going to be
making peanut butter jelly sandwiches
yeah i mean there's a standard i mean
you want to know what the standard is
right sure um you're not going to go to
the nba if you never watch the nba right
if you don't think like damn kobe's dope
i'm gonna beat kobe you're never going
to nba right
right um
[ __ ] i lost my turn my bad my bad no
it's all good because i agreed with you
i got pissed off with that there's so
much [ __ ]
that you don't like i don't like people
just throwing fluff out there to like
i feel good i think that and the
audience that it hits is uh not the not
the the macro you know like who like all
this [ __ ] motivational stuff like i
think what's the [ __ ] motivational
stuff you don't like like uh lion lion
king holding up simba mufasa that's my
favorite movie of all time all right
what are you talking about say that
every [ __ ] movie you bring up nah
lion king's dope okay what are you
talking what's the [ __ ] motivation
stuff so that like oh like don't compare
yourself for to others uh you're running
your own race
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i mean to a certain
extent
we're not we're all in the same race we
use the same currency we're breathing
the same air we're in the same economy
we're in the same sport we're in the
show i'm just going to agrees right but
i think the point of that is to say like
yes know what the standard is but still
keep it in your own lane right because
as soon as you start going like oh my
competitor's doing this now i got to do
this
that's you being smart and
turning that into something real that's
not what they're saying and that's not
how the masses interpret it no no what's
the mass is interpreting it as like uh
i don't know i i just don't think it's
motivational i don't think it hits i
don't think it's a key point to change
someone's outlook on life what's
something that motivates you like what
what would that mean me to say in order
for you oh it's more realistic
like you [ __ ] suck so does everyone
else keep going yeah or what you said
before like i i see that before i cut
you off
when you said like i see them yeah i
compare myself to them it just doesn't
change my mood or day i get what he's
saying i think like
that's the hits i get i get what you're
saying but i don't have asperger's like
you so i don't know i'm not [ __ ] so i
don't know you're that you're the guy i
hate you see someone take a picture of
their phone at 4am and you're stoked yes
yeah no one else is like that they're
not you're like damn that's cool
a lot of people are like that wake up at
3 59. no
no so for me like i like that they can't
do i understand what you're talking
about does it and i understand it um but
the difference is when i you know when
you're at the optometrist right it's
like number one number two what a
reference number three he's the king of
this [ __ ] right yeah i've never been to
an optometrist okay what
like let's say you're at the dmv you've
got the dmv perfect yeah the dmv don't
hate it you've got to do the idea
right and they cover the right eye do
you see this you see the left eye yeah
yeah yeah i've done the drivers or even
like colors like what do you see see
orange you see green they do that yeah
colors yeah let's see for colorblind oh
it's a little all the bubbles maybe when
i'm a kid all right okay yeah so you've
done different tests of different
perspectives oh right are you going
somewhere now yeah yeah so what i'm
saying is when i see
those blanket statements yeah i try to
understand that there's multiple
intentions to that statement and there's
also multiple audiences on the other
side sure so for example no [ __ ] tyson
fury fighting deontay wilder none of
their coaches are we're all winners here
you know it's go over there and beat the
living [ __ ] out of him yeah how many
like four how many corner uh like when
they put the audio there and the ufc
unboxing good job bones jones you're
running your own race really well
like how many times have you heard that
or how many times have you this is when
the champions are made champion around
it's him or you right yeah that's what
you hear so i understand when you're
trying to be the best of the best even
in business it's literally the it's you
versus them right even apple versus
microsoft yeah for sure because at that
time the pie is getting cut so much it's
this 50 or this 47 percent and you have
40
and everyone's getting closer to like 50
50 if there's only two big conglomerates
right
but at the regular person level right if
she's a youtuber i'm a youtuber
we will almost never cross territories
so i think when people are giving that
motivation they're like you know there's
literally trillions of views out there
if you focus on your hundred thousand
views you focus on 100 000 views you're
all in the same lane you're good but as
you
move up yes your the territories will
get i got too many thoughts dude no the
territories will get close yeah right i
mean when the shark becomes amphibious
and the lion knows how to swim yeah
they're gonna start battling it out but
oh i can't wait but there's i'll watch
this there's so many levels like the
amateurs like the lions winning the pro
am level the pro level and then the
championship level so so when i read
those things i think uh yes there's no
context but it can be dissected so many
different ways maybe this is me being a
hater you probably are not aspergers
how dare this guy stay at you have asked
like a mother and that's what i'm
calling about
i'm not no i'm neuro-divergent what the
hell does that mean i think it's the
same i think it's the 2021 version oh
okay uh
so
i guess two examples so i guess uh
honestly it is me being realistic or
maybe a hater but i believe um
i'm trying to think which reference to
go to first you said it was limitless
but it's not what you said it was
limitless in there but no it is it's
going so fast so let's go the bones
jones one or the the the thing in the
corner yeah yeah whatever whatever big
fighters in the corner yeah if they're
in the corner
tired winning the round losing the fight
and they're already thinking i'm not the
championship guy yeah i already think
they lost they lost yes i think their
coach yelling them at them isn't
changing how what's going on in their
brain i think the energy their coaches
yelling at them yes may help them uh
feel better and know that they have
support but it's not and
what can i say right i've never been a
champion at [ __ ] but i do watch a lot of
things read a lot of things and really i
think about this a lot on my own i don't
think bones jones is sitting there like
yeah my couch believes in me i'm going
to go knock this guy out now he's
already thinking in his head like i'm a
mother bro
no no he he already viscerally knows
literally i'm a bad [ __ ] and now
this coach is getting me chills because
he's yelling at me i didn't hear a word
he said but let's get this right so i
think there's power in the energy there
not in the words
sometimes uh and so and and going back
so let's go to the opposite end um the
youtuber that may be
feeling a little paralysis by analysis
looking up to the quants and saying man
their youtube channel 12 years they
built a career on it they built a life a
family a good living and look how many
views and subs they have and all the
businesses they get to run underneath
that i could never do that and they're
sitting there and they can't even
they're frozen editing their first video
right because they're like this isn't
good enough to put out there yep i don't
think that person has what it takes to
be a big youtuber regardless of what i
tell them you could put them through the
best youtube master class and if you go
that deep and we all had those moments
if you if you get frozen for an hour
that's fine and then you still put out
your youtube video a week from now even
a year from now five years from now at
least you did it but my point is like
that person getting a motivational
speech ran your own race honey is it
gonna just flip a switch and all of a
sudden she's putting in sick content but
doesn't that kind of go against your 12
years of chipping away because i think
everyone starts there frozen right and
you just chip away you're like well i
will release my first video and as they
start having momentum maybe they'll read
that and they you know jog a little bit
faster
i think uh i think maybe i i base too
much on destiny i guess or genetics or
or or the human individual but i don't
think i don't think humans are as
malleable by the outside is that
we're stubborn little creatures
and so like if you're so i think i think
sometimes it can be a flip of a switch
like that like if the right words are
said at the right time when you're able
to understand uh maybe everything lined
up sure yeah but how often does that
happen the same reason i call you ugly
like i know you're confident you know
like you're a pretty lady like i'm not
gonna like you know like i'm a pretty
lady
i'm not gonna call you [ __ ] ugly all
the time if i think it's actually gonna
hit you yeah yeah yeah you know what i
mean and same thing with that youtube
person if you're like run your own race
doll and then they [ __ ] go i don't
think it's contradictory to the 12 year
thing because i think the individual
that would be able to handle something
for 12 years is a different mindset well
i also think there are triggers though
right like a guy that's
down in the dumps getting his ass beat
12 rounds right yeah and then the coach
maybe just needs to say
your daughter oh you may and then a
transformation could happen right then
and there you know maybe maybe but that
goes back to my point of who's the
message hitting
it's what i'm saying there's a lot of
receivers on this side and there's a lot
of intent
i think there's less i think there's
less receivers to run your own race and
memes and and then my other issue is uh
what's the true motivation or intent
behind these people doing that is it is
it altruistic trying to motivate someone
or are you just trying to prove is it a
self consciousness
to me also you're tough you're tougher
than me you you telling me how hard you
work out
i don't care but also i think on this
side of receivers and this is this might
be where you agree with a little more
i think on the results end of it yeah i
think it's also different too oh for
sure so the receiver is a lot of people
receiving it sure you could follow
through and there's a lot of people that
might read that and they go that's true
we're all running our own race and they
feel good and it stops there yeah they
literally they put it in their story
like trill hard eyes and then they
literally don't and they don't progress
after that that's what i hate about the
whole thing so then it just feels so
yeah there are there are circles where
it's literally like patching on the back
you feel good i'll patch back every day
and they feel like they're doing
something yeah but there's also circles
where i think they see those things and
it really clicks and they're and it's
your daughter and i think your daughter
for sure but i've never heard anyone
like we've talked on-air off-air things
and geo never said like yeah man i heard
that rocky balboa speech and i decided
to vlog for 12 years straight
or i decided to really get back after
the gym like we've talked about your
your motivation and my motivation being
similar ish with how we work out or
don't work out or who we work out for
why we work out and neither of us said
yeah that uh
that
[ __ ] lebron james tweet really got me
yeah right it's like no i dug into my
[ __ ] i figured it out i had to take a
break i think i think i think the
purpose of these memes right and these
positive memes are to create some sort
of positive change whose purpose that's
the creative person creating it i don't
know yeah i think it is i think it's
just it connected with them somehow and
they're like oh [ __ ] this is this for me
yeah well let me let me pay it forward
i'm a hater maybe you are no i am
because i i think in the instagram world
the purpose of that is to get likes
because it's popular right now to post
that maybe and then and then on the
other end me being an extra hater the
people that create that stuff or tweet
that stuff all day i think like the
grind content yes [ __ ] like that is just
to show off like
like virtually virtually sometimes yes
that i think these are all these things
are true and this goes back to like the
one thing that i'm proud of is like i
think i've always stuck to who i am
with [ __ ] like that no i'm not for sure
i think i'm so aware i think all forms
of that stuff can all co-exist though no
i can't they can't i'm not trying to
shut nobody down or can't yeah buddy you
do whatever talk [ __ ] to all the foreign
people i will talk [ __ ]
i do talk [ __ ] i do and if you're a 4am
guy because it's the same idea though
like i'm just realistic with it like if
you got to wake up at 4am i know you're
not you're not productive for 16 hours
you're not
so who are you to shame me if i'm more
productive sleeping until 7. well they
might be taking a nappy nap yeah exactly
so then so then you're not that tough
you gotta go take a nappy nap with your
boo bear i'm [ __ ] waking up you're
talking about the person that's being
kind of like uh like a hard ass about it
yeah like the gate they're like gate
keeping toughness and hard work
hard work doesn't have to happen at 4am
productivity doesn't have to have i
think that i'll that also might be
insecure you're projecting me no because
i've done that yeah but what i'm saying
is i don't think i don't i don't even
think some people might use 4am as a
gatekeeper right if you don't wake up
for your [ __ ] yeah but some people
might just be promoting something and
they're not even there is no gate
they're just like this is what i do i
try to get up for above the crowd so i
get an edge on the competition and
that's it there's no gate and if you
want to wake up at seven i think you're
a badass too i think there's people like
that too i've never heard anyone tell me
that well that's the fine print they're
not gonna there's only the the [ __ ]
character no they're saying if you wake
up at seven year old puss
i'll wake up early or i'll like i'll
show what time i'm wait like i did it
today on my story like i'm going to
follow you oh 6 a.m and i think for me
when i do it it's it's never to be the
gatekeeper event i mean you know me man
like i i don't have that ego of like oh
i'm better than anyone else i don't
think i'm better than anyone um i just
think i myself mate thank you i
appreciate it no i think i'm better than
that oh no you're definitely not you're
average
um but i'll do it because i know like so
i get motivation from seeing other
people do that right or
self-accountability for yourself uh not
even that well yeah i don't even but i
get all that i do i do but i just think
the mass is i think that the market we
are in and even the gen pop stuff uh
that's just like what's trending right
now and i don't like it because it
doesn't feel real like you're not
teaching me anything maybe your
motivation is motivating a small group i
think that's not for you then no it's
definitely i've known that yeah so i'll
see [ __ ] like that right and i see who's
doing it and i and and i've lived enough
life now where i'm like oh i know what
phase in your life you're at no i me too
but but i guess my issues is like i
really actually do want to help folks
and and i don't think that helps the
masses like you said like i think some
people but i think it does you do i do
this is why i think it does
and i think that's what you were kind of
touching on it's even if it makes just
like one percent of a change where it's
like man i'm having a shitty mood but
hey yeah i am going to stay in my own
lane i feel better and it just helps you
for those 10 minutes oh maybe i think it
did its job right because now it depends
on the complexity of the person the
maturity of the person the person's
background like what phase in their life
they're at like
incredible huh i hate them all no you
don't so like for me and gio for example
right
um we did a 4am face yeah and uh now
we're not because it's it's really tough
right and it's not very sustainable but
when the pandemic first hit we didn't
know what was going to happen
uh taika couldn't play anywhere we're
like okay now we got to do full-time two
or three jobs and be a parent
and it might not have been the first
time i heard 4am but i've heard the
first time i heard that concept is from
eli the hip-hop preacher oh yeah you
know he'll they'll put his tracks
over like what do you want to succeed
yeah yeah as much as you want to breathe
yeah yeah look i was 19 listen to that
but yeah yeah i get it i get it sorry
i've heard that right it's like it's in
my my subconscious somewhere i've heard
that so there's there that's that first
point second point i've heard that is
mike tyson wakes up at 4am right yeah
it's in my little my little brain
wrinkles right then as a recent jackal
jocko's are promote promoting that right
so now that there's more and more and
more like when there's two dots make a
line more dots might make a picture
finally i get this picture and i'm like
oh [ __ ] you know what i do have it in me
to run all the businesses during a
pandemic and be a dad we're going to
start this 4 a.m thing and we were doing
it for like i don't know a month or two
months straight and i think it takes
a couple of these phrases from different
walks of life to kind of because you
to form this picture in your brain
you're like you know what i can't do
this and then you kind of are able to
pick yourself up my argument though is
that that was already you though
i knew that i i not that you did it or
you thought you could do it but if you
would ask
so you're right but i think you start
aligning with the things that make you
more of you right that make you fall
into the place that you're the most
comfortable in yes we're those type of
people but then there's also people that
like are like night owls they're artists
sure and they want to stay up late at
night and when the world is sleeping now
this is when i create so i think it's
whatever you align with and i think
that's why it's really cool to have
these memes and have these motivational
little things um because it's just it's
just you're hearing these positive
things coming at you and little by
little you start formulating and keeping
kind of like bruce lee right you take
what's useful and then you throw away
what's not necessary and then you create
your own [ __ ] you want my my lateral
step to my biggest pet peeve of this
whole thing is the term of like
discipline especially when it's wrapped
into fitness um and some of these guys
made some of the guys you even mentioned
might might have uh fall into that
argument for me is that
discipline has nothing to do with
repeatedly doing something you enjoy
true right that's not different would
you call me would you call me a
disciplined eater i love food and i get
to eat three meals a day yeah i've eaten
three meals a day geo for 33 years yeah
every single day and i'm sure about that
i'm a disciplined [ __ ] 400
pounds after yeah
and it's especially uh driven home and
fitness yep i did three sets of like
[ __ ] you loved a dead left like you
have a barbell tattooed on you and now
you're you know like you're [ __ ]
disciplined like you you you've spent
half your paycheck on supplements and
you hate the chimp no
a passion you love this [ __ ] and it's a
choice yeah right how are you with your
loved ones how are you when you have an
anger issue and you decide not to to hit
your spouse that's discipline to me like
you got a chemical imbalance in your
[ __ ] brain you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you don't pay your bills you beat your
wife but you wake up at 4 a.m to go work
out right like those things is what gets
me like if you liked it and and it's i
think it's proven genetically for sure
it's proven that um some people just
need less sleep there's a small
percentage of people that only need like
four hours of sleep and they're just as
highly functioning as the average folk
need like seven hours of sleep
and you wake up at 4am like no dude like
you're a morning person or like you're
talking about the night out i don't
think a creative is like
the typical artist that likes to do
their work at 3am like you're not more
disciplined than anyone else because you
like to draw at 2am and i draw at 2pm uh
and then are you saying that these
people are saying that they're
disciplined and but you're like nah
you're really passionate when i hear
that [ __ ] it comes from the people
following those people saying how do you
stay so motivated how do you stay so
disciplined it's a reaction rather than
right i think a bit of both i think a
bit of both my point is that these
people may not and obviously i'm [ __ ]
throwing a deep swipe here right there's
tons of people that are disciplined
there's tons of people that i don't like
working out i've never loved
powerlifting i've said that for 10 years
yeah i work out because it's just part
of what i do but it's not like i love it
i can't tell you the last time i was
stoked to work out like it's been
forever um and some of these people
might be like that too and i do consider
myself semi-disciplined i'm not a beast
i'm semi-disciplined um
i think the people following it can't
understand because they are wired
differently for sure like the 4am stuff
like man i can't even wake at eight wake
up at 8am that's for sure a part of it
um but my issue lies in again the intent
of the the person putting it out there
like are you just relying on what you're
good at
and you're just putting it out there
like you're a tough guy right like
that's like it's just fake to me it's
just fake i get it i mean
you just hate when it is fake you're
just like bro shut the [ __ ] up like
don't preach some [ __ ] if it's not the
truth yeah and maybe that has to do with
the sports stars i followed growing up
or or maybe my dad and just like like
acting like you've been there before
kind of mentality i think that's more of
a the gripe that you have is actually
towards fakeness
i don't think it's towards because i
think like the 4am or the discipline or
whatever i think i don't think those
concepts intrinsically are whack a
little bit a little bit too though
because my issue is if you can't give me
a reason why to do that that's uh a big
reason i was gonna go to the military
because i was just lost i didn't know
what to do after dropping out of
basketball all i knew was basketball i
was like where do i go but part of my
issue is like if you can't give me a
reason why i'm doing something i ain't
going to do it yeah and right they're
playing mind games like you're doing 100
burpees and if you ask them well how's
that actually going to help my
conditioning though shut the [ __ ] up and
now you got 200 right yeah yeah yeah uh
i can't do that and so when you're just
saying like wake up at 4am because i'm a
badass like you're not like you could be
just as productive or more productive at
any hour he would like
no that's that's true you know what i
mean but what i'm saying is i think uh
because now you're you're generalizing
right with that [ __ ] so what i think
i'm not attacking one person yeah i'm
attacking like the industry yeah but
what i'm saying is i think what i think
your true gripe is is if someone
preaches the 4am stuff yeah but the rest
of their
posts don't hold up that argument or
their life not even just post
life because we don't know what's going
on
that's what i think you
you have a problem because if someone is
preaching the 4am right yeah and they
are bulletproof and that's literally
what they do all the time
and they're not even talking about and
they're not even calling other people
[ __ ] yeah i feel like then all
they're doing is they're preaching their
religion yeah that's fine and then if if
he's there all they're doing is this
benefited me maybe you guys can try and
benefit yourselves yeah you just put it
in such a good way i've never seen
someone talk like that though
i do that [ __ ] well i think there's
different i don't preach anything i
think there's different religions though
you know different religions they have
different ways of like marketing yeah
and then so some people like like some
people like david goggins because he's
cusses and he's real or whatever right
and then some people they like the more
flowery words or the more like uh you
know
what is it like words of affirmation so
i think people are just aligning
themselves with the right religion to
get them back on track yeah like for me
like i don't ever i don't think i'm an
expert at anything i don't think i've
ever been an expert in anything um even
if i do become an expert in something
i'll never feel like i'm the expert
right and i'll never preach that i'll
never try to coach anyone i'll never try
to do anything all i ever try to do uh
is just put my life out there and it fit
aligns with people and people get
anything positive out of it then i'm
like sick i've said the same
regardless i'll share it because it's
just like it's fun for me yeah um and
and
yeah i just put it out there you take
what you can but neither of you guys
have ever put out those vibes you guys
have never been fake i always call
people [ __ ] yeah you're calling
someone a [ __ ] but you do go hard
you're one of the few because i've been
around you 24 hours i and maybe these
other [ __ ] do too you know like
maybe they do maybe they don't but the
point is it just doesn't feel authentic
to me sometimes it doesn't feel genuine
the intent behind it often doesn't feel
and then i just find like so many
loopholes in it like why no one's ever
told me why i gotta wake up before i am
like i've already got three cups of
coffee 10 000 push-ups in before you
woke up like yeah man but then you're
taking a nappy poo later and i'm working
well you're not
you know what i mean like yeah that's
cool i just had my coffee an hour later
why why is that better or why are you
better yeah yeah i feel like some people
make it like a pedestal thing like a
tough guy thing well i think that's
where i'm more like a [ __ ] myself we're
like like dude we're all just on this
planet like what do you
what what yeah it feels like a jock
bully mentality yeah i think there's a
lot of difference
if we if we speak
literally
and specifically
thing the whole point of that i think at
least from what i have understood it
came from the boxing culture where what
they're really trying to reinstate is in
boxing it's a one-on-one sport right so
the whole concept of being a better
boxer is you have to outwork the other
person and you have to be doing the
things that the other person isn't doing
sure so by starting with who knows what
time they're waking up but if you can
wake up at a time that you don't even
want to wake up you're already
ingraining that mental muscle of i'm
gonna get in before you right before
practice starts i'm gonna leave after
practice ends so i'm always doing more
and then that helps build this mental
toughness and championship mentality
in the ring sure it's just 4am became
this metaphor right right but rocky
balboa all that he's jogging when it's
raining i get it i do and i love a good
[ __ ] nah you're a hater dude i love i
love a little rocky you're like okay
rock you want to just jog with umbrella
and like same thing like i respect kobe
to the fullest you know but like he's
shooting thousand free throws after
every game 100 yeah but but he's not
like flex into the world like i'm up at
three like he like not only from like a
strength and conditioning evidence-based
like your hour of sleep is going to do
you better yeah yeah but it's also
different when you compare that to
someone that's on social media right
because for sure uh now we're talking
about a [ __ ] mega superstar that has
like the tv [ __ ] networks backing
them up whereas you have to prove
yourself online because it's just so
saturated so it's like how do you stand
out more than the others this other
person and it kind of goes into the
boxing mentality well i think that's
what i don't like is it feels like
they're just doing it to stand out
that's what i say i think it goes back
to you
having the gripe against the fake part
of it rather than the actual concept i'm
not going to put some on an
instructional youtube or a podcast that
i don't actually think like
you honestly think that if all of
america starts to wake up before a.m
we're gonna be a better society or
you're they're gonna be better
individuals i don't
i knows man because it's so [ __ ] hard
it takes it takes you switching your
shitty self up yeah but uh the majority
of people are gonna get less sleep less
quality sleep they're going to have more
hunger but we're just going to get
fatter like i don't think it's a i don't
think it's a good recipe you know what i
mean rather than like if i had a
preacher if i could snap my fingers and
make everybody do something like all
right everyone in america is going to
get seven hours of sleep
i think we'll be a better society no
joke yeah you know what i mean so like
what am i putting out to the internet
verse
like well because to help people because
there's multiple diseases and they have
different cures maybe right and i think
what you're talking about is hands down
sleep cures almost everywhere and you're
talking about the lazy guy that can't
get off the couch and so if i get up if
i get trust me i get it i think about
these things
i [ __ ] get it like if i if i'm
talking to the lazy guy and i'm showing
him how many deadlifts and 4am workouts
i did maybe he'll get off the couch for
a jog i understand the trickle effect
because you can't expect a couch potato
to just wake up at 4am and hop into the
barber brigade training program which is
available right now
thank you but right like
maybe he can get off the couch or put a
bag of chips down when he sees my
rippling abs as i'm jogging in the snow
i understand
that there may be positive effects from
it but i just think there's more
realistic ways and more authentic ways
um and i think uh so this is a hater
true um i know you keep [ __ ] around
but like ish yeah no no yeah i'm
definitely half serious for sure yeah
but i think i think if you keep looking
at things from that lens and yes it's
it's like a hater lens
um
then nothing's really going to happen
right like you're just going to feel
down because you can't control anything
at this point oh no no this bugs me
because i because i lead with my foot
you know well a little bit but it will
right because you'll look at things you
know like [ __ ] that blah blah blah blah
right but one thing i really like that
dave chappelle said not in this most
recent one but the his special before
that yeah uh he was just talking about
how [ __ ] up this planet is kind of
becoming right like
like people are just not in it for the
right reasons like even our leaders are
kind of sketched like there's just a
bunch of sketchy [ __ ] happening
and he's like basically saying you can't
control anything but yourself yes all
these things are gonna exist you can sit
there and be like [ __ ] i hate that i
hate that this is [ __ ] up
he's like but you're just gonna [ __ ]
get miserable and i'm adding more [ __ ]
to what he's saying yeah yeah no no i
guess but i think that's what i do right
because what would you ask me what i'm
most proud of it's like just being me
yeah so again like i lead by me
and i don't it's not my job to talk [ __ ]
or i don't plan on changing these people
but we just hopped on the conversation
and discipline and stuff and it is a
great because i i don't think those
i think there's better use of people's
audiences
yeah and i take a big responsibility and
have an audience
yeah um but i think so his i mean and i
know you got what his point is um but
for you guys listening uh he's just
basically saying hey i'm gonna make my
corner of the world beautiful right and
i think like you said right one foot in
front of the other you only have control
over that um and i think just really
grilling that and [ __ ] hitting that
note over and over again
is gonna make your corner of the world
really beautiful so if that means
unfollowing these people that make you
feel a type of way i think that's what
it should take yeah it really doesn't i
don't lose sleep trust me and if i met
all these four ammers in person i'm
gonna i'm gonna meet them with an open
mind i'm gonna i'm gonna see how they
act and i'm gonna judge them based on
how i meet them um but
it's more like the posting of that
nature yeah you know what i mean maybe
those people are sick and maybe they are
more disciplined than me there's a
billion people that are way more
disciplined than i i'm by far i eat like
trash you know i can't stick to a diet
myself tons of food problems right like
i went a whole year without working out
i'm supposed to be a fitness
professional like i've got issues left
and right but
um that's the most common thing when
people open gyms though
mine was before the opening oh really
mine was just a mental issue i get it no
but you made a [ __ ] career and a
living off of it you were
every time you lifted it wasn't ever
lifting for yourself you're lifting with
the [ __ ] camera in your face yeah
that's true so i get it dude it was
never for you like it started off for
you it was working out for basketball
you did that and then basketball stopped
and you're like cool i still enjoy
lifting you do that now there's a camera
in your face you're doing it for
immediately i get it bro like it's
burnout that's what burnout is oh we've
been burnt so
this podcast flew by yeah uh cause you
love talking about [ __ ] yeah and we've
pretty much done and it's 11 11 11 11.
love it make a wish yeah we're we're
meant to be here but um i always want to
i always like to leave the podcast with
one question with all our guests because
everyone has accomplished so much and
we're super inspired and admire
everything that all of our guests have
done
um with all the things and ups and downs
that you've done
and kind of like learning the skills
along the way your mentality your
tenacity your just discipline and all of
that like let's say you had to start all
over
but you're still the same mic you are
today with the same skills with the same
like willpower yeah would you have done
the exact same path
yeah it's a good question because i hate
that like uh i hate both i'm just a
hater dude
i hate when people are like i don't
believe in regrets i'm like all right
[ __ ] like there's something you regret
and then i hate the opposite side too
like man i wish i would have changed
everything yeah i believe in regrets
yeah yeah i uh i don't know um
i as a younger mike
i was extremely fearful of failure i was
more scared to fail than i was excited
to win and that held me back to
basketball a lot i had an opportunity to
play at a really big d1 school um they
asked me to come
walk on basically um which isn't like a
guaranteed invite but again for a 5 8
italian kid it's pretty much as good as
yeah to have an invite it's pretty crazy
yeah and they went to the they went to
the elite eight that year like i could
have sat the bench um and they've been
part of that team could have been
amazing and i ended up
how the universe works being friends
with that team uh through another path
one of the starting shooting guards
started dating one of my friends and we
became really good homies uh but i guess
i would have
a little bit more true confidence in
myself yeah um where i probably had what
it take to probably even get minutes on
that team um the starting point guard
was the same year as me and so they said
like oh you can come try out but we have
a really good point guard coming in long
story short that point guard's been in
the nba for 15 years wow
his name is patty mills he's an absolute
freak so like but even even that even
the coach looking me down in the eyes
and this coach is a really good coach he
said yeah we got a good point guard
coming under the table i was like oh
really good point guard you haven't seen
me play you know which is just like a
fake ego yeah move yeah and so i wish i
would have kind of eliminated some of
that and that probably held me back in
other portions of my life too that
aren't as blatant relationships or
self-growth or whatever um
but with the non-regret thing like
i was just i was 18. you know like if
that doesn't happen i don't
i'm not sad for the last 10 years that i
didn't play basketball and then learn
from it like why didn't i play you
needed it to happen to learn from it 100
i stopped myself i was you know and
everyone cliche [ __ ] that i talked
[ __ ] on uh you're your worst enemy but i
definitely have been um so i'd probably
be number one but otherwise like the
path is the path i mean there's other
things with business and stuff that i
that i i wasn't happy with things how
went over or even relationship stuff
where i maybe felt like i got taken
advantage of uh because i like to put
you know my heart out there and my best
foot forward but yeah you can't learn if
you don't [ __ ] it up and that's cliche
too uh so you're just being a basic
[ __ ] and going i hate myself as well so
you would just say you would probably do
the same thing over again because you
because the lessons that you've learned
made you who you are for sure for sure
that's like the that's the cliche answer
but it really is the truth like i i
think i'm pretty self-aware for or
already the age i'm at yeah it's because
i think i had a little bit of a and
trust me people have it way worse than
me i'm not saying that by any means but
i've had like i've had speed bumps in my
path my path has been very clear and
very nice i'm very lucky kid by all
means but within my little path of
italian kid playing basketball i had a
lot of bums yeah have you tried waking
up at 4am though yeah bro i did that for
a year dude sure i was in the gym at
five every day that's good all right
good for you bro stop putting it out
there like working 10 hour shifts in the
cold we don't got a heater in my gym and
we're not in l.a [ __ ] up that you're
we're not in l.a bro